we have a lot to learn from science and
from medicine yet sometimes it can be
difficult to understand exactly what we
know and what we need to know
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
today i am super excited to chat with dr
lloyd miner dean of the stanford school
of medicine
lloyd is a scientist surgeon and
academic leader he is the carl and
elizabeth nowman dean of the stanford
university school of medicine he is also
a professor of head and neck surgery and
a professor of bioengineering and
neurobiology
in 2020 he wrote the book discovering
precision health and he is also the host
of the minor consult podcast
well hi lloyd i'm really excited to have
you on the podcast and look forward to
our conversation thank you matt i'm
delighted to be here and i too look
forward to our conversation great let's
go ahead and get started
first to begin congratulations on your
podcast the minor consult i've listened
in and i enjoy it very much i'm curious
what led you to host a podcast and what
are you hoping to accomplish with it in
the early days of covet 19 when there
was a lot of information coming out a
lot of science being done a lot that we
didn't know
i started doing some media appearances
really to try to explain
what we do know and what we don't know
to serve i hope as a trusted information
source
and i enjoyed doing that and got good
feedback on it and really continued to
do that throughout
the pandemic not that we're out of the
pandemic yet but throughout the shall we
say that the pre-vaccination stage and
vaccine roll-out stage of the pandemic
and
so i was looking for a way to continue
that process of communicating with
uh a large group of people um anyone who
wants to listen and hopefully through
the podcast
also learn from the guests the podcast
is about leadership it's about
leadership in a crisis
and i've had the privilege of
interviewing guests from different
professions and and interests and i've
learned a lot from it hopefully the
listeners have as well
i think one of the central messages of
the pandemic to me and i'll be
processing these past two plus years for
the next how many every year i think
yeah but one of the central messages is
we need to be
more thoughtful about more engaged with
the way we communicate i think that's
particularly true
um in the science and in medical
communities where i i don't think our
communication has always served the
public
uh well or or the scientific interests
well i hope we can start that
conversation today given that we focus a
lot on communication and and i just want
to give you a personal nod and thank you
during the pandemic you certainly
provided a steady hand and some good
clear advice during times of confusion
both for me personally i know for my
colleagues and on the campus and
actually in our general area so thank
you for that and i'll just echo hosting
a podcast is a fantastic way to learn i
i have learned so much and i am sure i
will learn a ton from you as well
speaking of learning i recently learned
that you consider yourself an introvert
i'm very curious to learn
how your introversion has helped you be
successful and further i'd love to hear
your advice tips or tricks
you have for many of our listeners who
consider themselves introverts and for
those of us who might not be introverted
what we could do to help our colleagues
and our friends who are if one adopts
the definition of introvert extrovert is
terms of how you recharge so classically
extroverts recharge by being
uh immersed with others and introverts
recharge by
uh being with themselves or a very small
group of people or person that they have
is particularly trusted advisor or or
spouse in my case my wife uh
and uh i think that that describes my
personality in terms of how i recharge
now what i've learned about myself and
in leadership in particular
is
um you know one of the reasons i feel
like i have the best job on the planet
is that i interact with so amazing such
a group of amazingly bright people on a
daily basis through what i do at
stanford university in stanford medicine
and then more broadly
as a representative of stanford and as a
as a leader in biomedicine
and
i
derive a lot of energy from those
interactions and from learning from
others
but in order to process and really
sort of plan
then i need to have time to think and
sort things out
individually or with a small group of
others
thank you for sharing that i think for
those who listen in who are introverted
to hear that their approach is equally
valuable and in some cases more valuable
i it can be very affirming and to
recognize that we need both types of
people those who are extroverted and i
fall into that category and those who
are introverted to make things work well
you mentioned listening in your response
to my question about introversion and i
was really struck by a quote i heard of
yours it went one of the most active
things that i do is to listen to process
what i'm hearing and to come up with
informed questions that bring us
together
can you share your thoughts on the
importance of listening beyond what
you've already shared around
introversion and provide us with any
best practices you personally use to
listen well sure
i think the most valuable clerkship
that i had in medical school was my
psychiatry clerkship and it's because
of something that our preceptor did for
there are two of us students rotating
with our preceptor that time and for the
it was a six week rotation for
every day at least three days a week
each of us would interview a patient um
we weren't allowed to take notes
and the other person would be listening
and after the interview each of us
independently would write we were asked
to write verbatim what we heard during
that 30-minute interview and discussion
with the patient
and at first
it was extraordinarily difficult i mean
it was just the hardest thing in the
world and
but it became i wouldn't say easy but it
became easier with time of the
experience and the point is you really
have to concentrate and focus if you're
going to really listen
and i've tried to deploy that in the
other things i've done as a surgeon
scientist as a leader it really does
help first it helps to build trust in
others if they really can see that
you're listening it helps to really have
a dialogue if
in addition to
what you're saying you're actually
heeding what others say
and that comes back
in the way you converse with them that
they know that you're listening to them
i've always emphasized that i think
listening is the most important trait
and characteristic of leadership and
undergirds the success in every other
area of leadership and i don't think it
receives enough attention as we're
talking about leadership training and as
we're talking about communication
certainly what we say is important
but it's even more important that what
we are saying
is based upon what we're taking in from
listening to others so what i'm hearing
you say really is that you need to take
the time to listen really focus and
concentrate on it it is a it is an
important and an act that requires a lot
of attention and it can really breed
connection and validate others and
that's that's an important part of
leadership and i agree as somebody who
teaches communication a lot of what gets
taught is how to say your piece not
necessarily how to listen to what the
other people are saying
during your tenure as the dean of the
stanford school of medicine you've had
to address many significant issues
happening on campus and beyond what are
your thoughts on the role of leaders in
communication in times of ambiguity and
challenge any insights that you've
learned
i think one insight is when someone
doesn't know the answer to a question
or when they answer the question is
simply not known we need to say that we
don't know
and i think
a lot of experts
early on in the pandemic that was
problematic because that really wasn't
being stated and there was so much we
didn't know
and in a sense it's not reassuring but
it's far more of a problem if we try to
pretend we do and then later on of
course
we didn't
so i think
being honest being forthright following
through it's a specific question i
simply don't know the answer to
but the answer is out there
then i should be finding out the answer
and then relaying that back the idea is
to rather than pushing ambiguity away
we should lean into it and use it as a
stimulus
to guide our communication in more
effective ways one of the things that i
really respected about you and some of
your colleagues who who became front and
center in the news on a regular basis
was the level of transparency that you
would admit we don't know or we're
learning or we said this one day and now
we know this as well so
in addition to saying i don't know i
think it's important to to put a a focus
on transparency as well and i saw that
played out often in your communication
i've heard you talk about authentic
leadership can you tell us what you mean
by that and and why is this type of
leadership so important to you to me
authenticity means
you know being forthright being honest
being empathic for sure it means putting
yourself in the shoes of the other
person it means earning the right to be
a leader which is something it doesn't
come with a title it doesn't come with
resources
to be an effective leader you need to
earn that right that privilege that
trust from
the people that you're leading and that
look to you for leadership i think
authenticity is something today that
particularly given the impact of social
media and the immediacy of social media
oftentimes
authenticity is not represented in a
in a sound bite or in a tweet in fact if
anything it it gets us further away from
authenticity i think there's a basic
yearning today in society to
to have some bedrock truths to
to understand our differences better
than we do today
and to be authentic expressing those
differences and expressing those views
but hopefully from the authenticity when
it exists on both sides of an issue
when that authenticity is there that
will help actually help people work
together even though they disagree
and i think we're sorely like lacking
that right now i'm curious as you think
about authentic leadership what's the
role of feedback it seems to me that
feedback would be an important part of
that i'm curious how that works for you
it's essential to building trust another
trait that helps in building trust is
to be vulnerable and goodness knows
we were all of us but in particular
those of us in leadership
have throughout covid um whether or not
we acknowledged it it or not we've been
extraordinarily vulnerable and i think
to
acknowledge that look we
we may not get this right and we depend
upon your feedback to recalibrate and
get it right
that that's that's just absolutely
essential by discipline i'm trained as
an ear surgeon as a lateral skull-based
surgeon and
those are
highly precise fields and when i became
provost at johns hopkins i stopped
operating because if you're not doing it
regularly you shouldn't be doing it the
point is that your best opportunity
to do good for your patient is the first
time you do do something
and do it
absolutely
textbook right the first time and there
is there is a clear right and wrong with
most things in in my clinical field you
know leadership is very very different
from that i find myself rarely do i get
it right the first time i depend upon
the feedback of others
unless this is
you know a critically important time
sensitive decision and we were faced
with many of those during covid in those
cases you do the best you can and you
recalibrate very quickly
in cases that are not as acute as they
have been during covid you can
put up a straw person you can
float an idea
you can express your opinion and your
belief about this is the way we think we
i think we should go
some of that will be embraced some of it
won't but if you take the feedback it's
not going to affect your credibility as
a leader it's very different than a
surgical procedure you know you want to
tell a patient before you do a surgical
procedure you know i think i'm going to
do it this way today but that may not
work and so you know we'll we'll then do
something different tomorrow or next
week i mean no one wants to hear that
right and for me that was um
that was a recalibration as a leader and
i feel really fortunate to have had kind
of both sides represented and i think
it's made me able to act definitively
when the circumstance requires it and
when people around me expect me to act
definitively
and also to be
more graduated and incremental when the
situation
justifies that approach
i think it's great that you take the
time to reflect on feedback and to be
and are so open to it before we end i
i'd like to ask you the same three
questions i ask everyone who joins me
are you up for that i sure am excellent
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would that be empathic
listening for impactful leadership oh i
like it and even it even has some
rhyming to it
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why rue
simmons former president of brown
university current president of prairie
view a m um i got to know ruth when she
was president of brown as a brown alum
ruth asked me to serve on a corporation
committee on medical education many
years ago
and i think ruth's ability to lean into
complex controversial topics
and to
through
the strength of her personality and her
intellect
really get people to do their best
thinking
uh around an issue and come up with
recommendations i think she's
extraordinary at that
final question
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe listen
learn
recalibrate
i think to learn you have to listen we
talked a lot about that today but you
also had to be willing to
to say look i probably got that wrong
before
and and you've got to be willing to say
that first to yourself and then you've
got to be willing to say that to others
and then seek the input from others that
help
you and others get it right moving
forward well dean miner thank you so
much for being here the work you and all
of your colleagues do at the stanford
medical school is so important
and a personal thank you for all that
you
and everyone there did during the
pandemic
i appreciate your time and your
thoughtful and thought-provoking ideas
and actions around effective leadership
and the importance of communication in
science and medicine finally best of
luck on your podcast the minor consult
everyone listening in
has a lot to learn from you and your
guests thanks a lot matt
[Music]
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by michael
riley jenny luna and me matt abrahams
find more resources and connect with us
online by searching for think fast talk
smart on linkedin we'd love to connect
there be sure to follow us on linkedin
as well
download more episodes and subscribe to
us wherever you get your podcasts